Feridun delay is alone in a foreign land
his wife and child have already made it
to Germany he planned to follow them but
the pact between the EU and Turkey means
he's stuck in Istanbul even if he and
his friends make it to Greece the threat
of deportation looms large it's a
catastrophe not only for myself but for
those who have already reached Greece
they've risked everything to make it
this far there's nothing here for them
in Turkey the district of ax RI in
Istanbul normally the square is teeming
with migrants and the middlemen who
arranged their illegal passage to Greece
today the square is emptier than usual
demand for life vests for the perilous
sea crossing has dried up one angry
trader leaves his store and approaches
our camera his frustration is shared by
the migrants with their passage to
Western Europe effectively blocked they
don't know what to do next he is the
only one who will show us a way out of
this situation one possibility would be
through the new one-for-one program for
each Syrian returned to Turkey one will
be resettled in Europe but Fardeen de la
isn't hopeful they'll take in 70,000 of
us but I don't expect to be amongst them
they'll likely take those in the refugee
camps or those registered by the United
Nations anyone waiting to be reunited
with their family like me he and his
friends can do is wait and hope